the White House Correspondents Dinner
goes off the rails joy Reid apologizes
sort of and Kanye meets with Candice
Owen charlie Kirk and issues a new rap
about Trump Wow lot going on I'm Ben
Shapiro this is Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
see the thing about reality TV is that
you always thought that reality TV was a
distillation of reality that it was
taking a reality and then distilling it
well it turns out instead that you're
actually living inside a giant reality
TV show that there is actually a
producer in the sky and he's created a
reality TV show you're a character and
you don't even know it because that's
the only way to explain what the hell is
going yeah no with everything we're
gonna get to all of this all of the news
because there's a lot of news and all of
it is intensely stupid we'll get to all
of it in just a second first I want to
say thanks to our sponsors over at my
Patriot supply so earlier this month the
agency director over at FEMA said FEMA
is not a first responder which is true
you are the first responder in case of
emergency if there's some sort of
natural disaster or man-made disaster
the real question is are you prepared
because you are your own first line of
defense well this is the week to stock
up on emergency food get the Ben Shapiro
special offer from my Patriot supply
right now you can get one for weak
emergency food kit for only 198 bucks
and you get one free so you buy one you
get one free and if you purchase one
right now my Patriot supply will send
you an additional four week food kit for
free call eight eight eight eight oh
three 14 13 or order online and prepare
with been calm all of the food lasts and
storage for 25 years tastes like home
cooking according to the folks who work
here at the office and again once you
buy it it's in your closet you don't
have to worry about it until something
terrible happens then you say oh I'm
sure glad that I prepared with that so
go check it out right now prepare with
Ben's comm 8 8 8 8 o 3 14 13 8 8 8 8 o 3
14 13 or prepare with Ben comm make sure
that you're not the one caught with your
pants down if God forbid something
terrible is to happen in the world make
sure that you have taken care of your
family pretty easy deal one four week
emergency food kit for 198 bucks and you
get one for free prepare with Ben comm
lets them know that we sent you as well
okay so the big story over the weekend
was of course the White House
Correspondents Dinner I hate the White
House Correspondents Dinner I think it's
stupid I think that it is
self-aggrandizing every year I complain
about it there's been four probably 10
years running I say that it's just
ridiculous to have all of these
journalists sitting there in tuxes
feeding each other and talking about how
wonderful they are and then patting each
other on the back and have this roast
there's one event every year that is
made to order to make Americans feel as
though they are out of the loop and
scorned by the media elite it is the
White House Correspondents Dinner
we were actually invited to a White
House Correspondents Dinner
I did not go I really am not
particularly interested in going it
doesn't look like a very fun event to be
at honestly it's just a place for for
people to hobnob with each other when
they talk about Washington DC cocktail
parties this is exactly the sort of
thing they are talking about well
everything was going sort of as planned
as per the usual arrangement the White
House Correspondents Dinner a bunch of
rich people famous people patting each
other on the back and talking about
wonderful they are and making some sort
of light jokes about one another and
then Michelle wolf got up now I don't
know I'd never heard of this person
Michelle wolf and you guys heard of
Michelle wolf before this I've never
heard of Michelle wolf before this I
just figured to choose some sort of
Debbie wasserman-schultz impersonator I
had no clue who she was and she gets
apparently it turns out that she's a
writer for Comedy Central which
demonstrates presumably why Trevor Noah
is deeply unfunny
I guess this explains a lot of things
that explains Trevor Noah explains
Samantha bees prior history I don't know
if she wrote for either of those shows
but if not then she does a lot of
compete reott or just as unfunny as she
is so Michelle wolf gets up when she was
a 19 minute monologue and we're not
gonna play for you this 90-minute
monologue because I watched it and it
probably took four years off my life
just in terms of sheer boredom and I was
just watching it and I could feel my
hair turning gray I it was like the end
of Indiana Jones and and the Holy Grail
is like that is like I drunk from the
wrong cup by the end of the amount of
monologue I'd added several gray hairs
and several wrinkles to my forehead but
Michelle wolf did this monologue and
it's been much ballyhooed people on the
left many of them defending it some
people on the left not defending it
people on the right of course very very
upset about I want to talk about this
because I want to talk about the value
of humor in Trump era America I don't
talk about the media's response to all
of this as a precursor let it be noted
no one made a joke about Obama for eight
years at the White House Correspondents
Dinner it was forbidden you're allowed
to make jokes about Paul Ryan about
Mitch McConnell about Mitt Romney about
John McCain you're allowed to make jokes
about a bunch of foreign leaders you
were not allowed to make jokes that were
serious about Barack Obama and this is
why Seth Meyers and Cru we're making it
was great I mean if you're a Republican
president you could be attacked when you
order the president like bush or you
could be attacked when you were not the
president like Bush when Obama was
president so the White House
Correspondents Dinner has always become
a roast of the right which of course has
justified the right ones hatred of the
media one of the great lies the media
have put out over the past several years
is that President Trump is the one who
jinda
all of this dislike of the media that's
utter nonsense as I said at CPAC we
hated you guys before we thought you
guys sucked we thought that you were bad
at your job we thought that you were not
objective and you were pretending to be
objective we thought that you were
wildly left-wing so it's not a shock
really that michelle wolf was up there
ripping into president Trump but it was
the level of vitriol that she used it
was the it was the crazy level of
betrayal that she used that that got
people really upset particularly her rip
I'm Sarah Huckabee Sanders so Trump
declines to go but a bunch of members of
the White House were there so Kellyanne
Conway went I don't know why if you're
Kellyanne Conway you would go
Sarah Huckabee Sanders went I don't know
why if you're Sarah Huckabee Sanders you
would go you know you're gonna go there
you know you're gonna get roasted and
Michele will certainly roasted Sarah
Huckabee Sanders again in in quite
unfunny fashion and you know there are a
lot of folks out there you say that I
have an annoying voice folks you have
not heard annoying until you've heard
this voice oh here's Michelle wolf going
off on Sarah Huckabee Sanders I have to
say I'm a little star-struck I love you
as aunt Lydia and The Handmaid's Tale
my pants if you haven't seen it you
would love it
I actually really like Sarah I think
she's very resourceful like she burns
facts and then she uses that Ash to
create a perfect smoky eye like maybe
she's born with it maybe it's lies and
I'm never really sure what to call Sarah
Huckabee Sanders you know is it Sarah
Sanders is it Sarah Huckabee Sanders is
it cousin Huckabee is it auntie Huckabee
Sanders like what's Uncle Tom but for
white women who disappoint other white
women Coulter okay so number one it was
any of that funny like if you're on the
Left you find that funny maybe we just
have wildly different senses of humor
but I didn't find any of that funny like
I will laugh if there's a good anti
Trump joke because a good joke is a good
joke but that's not a good joke now a
lot of people were getting on wolf for
supposedly ripping on Huckabee Sanders
his looks I'm not hearing her rip on
Huckabee Sanders his looks right there
actually I didn't actually hear the
evidence that she's ripping on Sarah
Huckabee Sanders has looked she makes a
reference about smoky eye she makes a
reference about aunt Lydia from The
Handmaid's Tale which I believe is more
of a rip on Huckabee Sanders his
character I mean this is where we become
an American side you're allowed to say
that a woman wants other women to be
raped for purposes of impregnation which
is the which is actually the the role of
aunt Lydia in The Handmaid's Tale in The
Handmaid's Tale that Lydia his woman who
oversees all of the women who are raped
forcibly you know forcibly consummated
by men and then are forced to bear their
children and so that seems to me that
would be more of an insult than that
she's ugly but that's not but people
didn't take it that way you're not
allowed to attack Sarah Huckabee Sanders
on these grounds because presumably
there was some sort of covert joke there
about aunt Lydia being played by a not
very attractive woman in the series and
Sarah Huckabee Sanders looks like that
woman again I'm not hearing the the
evidence that Sarah Huckabee Sanders was
ripped on account of her looks I am
hearing a lot of very mean and stupid
jokes about Sarah Huckabee Sanders but
I'm not sure that it's that much wildly
beyond the pale of anything else Michele
Wolf said like for example I think her
rip on Mike Pence was just as bad as her
rip on Sarah Huckabee Sanders here's
what she said about my pens a lot of
people want Trump to be in
I do not because just when you think
Trump is awful you remember Mike Bettes
my fence is what happens when Anderson
Cooper isn't gay
my kind of guy that brushes his teeth
and then drinks orange juice and thinks
mmm
I don't even know what that means about
the orange juice and the toothbrushing
like well does he have no taste buds
what exactly is the idea there
in any case again making The Handmaid's
Tale reference about my pen sheets you'd
do that several times throughout the
evening and it's just you know again I
think bad comedy I don't think this is
wildly egregious here's what I do think
was wildly egregious so here is the
point where she is demonstrative what
the left thinks are you can hear the
entire crowd laughing at all of this
laughing along my pence is just terrible
Sarah Huckabee Sanders burns bags
ahahahahahaha and everybody in the
audience who's laughing understand that
you just undermined your credibility for
the next ten years with the entire
right-wing audience you guys are trying
to prove that Trump hates the media
because he's disrespectful of the truth
well you guys are disrespectful of a
very basic truth you are biased you are
left-wing you think these jokes are
funny you have to be left-wing you think
these jokes are funny or brain-damaged
those are the only two possibilities
because the jokes are not funny number
one and number two they're all very much
left-wing jokes and it'll be funny
because you'll hear at the end Michelle
wolf makes a couple of jokes actually
lectures and members of the media and
they do not take it well but here's the
here's the joke that got a laugh from
some members of the media that just
demonstrates full scale where the
media's heads are at the level of bias
in the media it's pretty astonishing
this is the one that should have shook
the room all right this is the joke that
people should have enough said about not
the stuff about Sarah Huckabee Sanders
look I understand we live in the me2
moment and we're supposed to have female
solidarity and if there's any sort of
implication then we'll miss it is
attacking another woman but that's
really terrible and all of this here's
the joke that I was offended by okay
because it turns out I like babies okay
I think babies are good here's the joke
that I was offended by here's Michelle
wolf
I'm telling an abortion joke I guess
that's what this says and it does
demonstrate anything full-scale what
folks on the Left think about abortion
which is pretty unfortunate my friends
is also very anti choice he thinks
abortion is murder which first of all
don't knock it till you try it
and when you do try it really knock it
you know you got to get that baby out of
it
and yeah sure you can groan all you won
I know a lot of you are very
anti-abortion you know unless it's the
one you got for your secret mistress
waiver ha ha ha ha and look at the look
at the expressions the media they're all
the smiles
oh the Oh isn't she charming oh so she
basically it's a baby it's not murder
but it's a baby you should really hit it
hard till it comes out of there and I'll
say y'all bought abortions to your
mistresses so now it's more all huh ha
ha ha ha ha ok the disrespect for human
life there I think is a lot more deeply
troubling from the left and the
disrespect for Sarah Huckabee Sanders
again so I think Sarah Huckabee Sanders
has a right to be mad yeah I mean this
wasn't a roast right if he were roast
Sarah Huckabee Sanders would get to get
up there and respond but Sarah Huckabee
Sanders is sitting there and I think
solidly taking it and and Kellyanne
Conway doing the same thing but that
joke is the one that I think is really
amazing and again you have to be not
only on the left but I think relatively
inhuman to think that that is a funny
joke I don't knock abortion until you
try it and if you do try it really knock
it cuz you got to get that baby out of
there Wow justjust hilarious hilarious
stuff now
there was one joke that did fall flat
for Michelle wolf among the people in
the audience and that was her rip on the
media so in just a second I'm gonna play
that for you because this actually was
the one point in her in her little
monologue that I thought was worthwhile
and then we'll get to all the reactions
to this and the demonstration at the
media and all of their quote-unquote
unbiased glory or anything anything but
unbiased but first I want to say thanks
to our sponsor is over at 1-800 flowers
so it's hard for you to find a bigger
fan of you than your mom well throughout
all of your life she's been supporting
well now you can actually do something
nice for her because Mother's Day is
coming up and this Mother's Day you can
show her how much you appreciate her
dedication with 1-800 flowers calm right
now when you get ahead of the Mother's
Day rush 1-800 flowers is giving you an
exclusive 24 424 offer 24 multicolored
roses for 24 bucks only a dollar per
rose it's such a good deal then when I
was on the road last week I actually
bought my wife I was gone for two days I
bought her two of these bouquet of
bouquets one for each day because
they're just beautiful with a bright and
beautiful mix of premium roses and
rainbow of colors the blooms are
guaranteed to show your mom or your wife
or any other lady in your life just
tells me how much she is loved
multi-coloured roses are a perfect way
to surprise all of the moms in your life
so check that out 24 multi colored roses
for only 24 bucks it's an amazing offer
but you have to hurry because that offer
does expire
on Thursday so pick your delivery date
1-800 flowers handles all of the rest
and by the way if something goes wrong
in transit they fix it for you it's
really fantastic 1-800 flowers calm and
again to order 24 stunning multicolored
roses for only 24 bucks go to 1-800
flowers calm Shapiro's use that / up
here for the special deal that's 1-800
flowers calm / Shapiro's use that / up
here you get a special deal and again
and let's know we sent you 1-800 flowers
calm / Schapiro okay so finally Michelle
wolf tells a joke that the media don't
like so the media like the jokes about
Sarah Huckabee Sanders they liked a
bunch of jokes about Mike Pence they
liked she did a really ridiculous
routine where she just talked about how
Trump is not all that wealthy which i
think is probably true I don't think
Trump is as wealthy as he says he is but
she actually started telling a series of
joke saying Donald Trump isn't as well
see who wealthy as he thinks he is he's
so poor that and then he should have the
audience say how poor is he and then
should give a giving a little joke at
the end in any case here is the only
thing the media did not laugh at her rip
at the media which is the only true
thing she said the entire night so
here's Michelle wolf again at the White
House Correspondents Dinner welcome guys
it's great to have you you guys love
breaking news and you did it
you broke it Fox News is here so you
know what that means ladies some of your
drinks seriously okay but then she went
on to rip into the media she suggested
that the media had made a bunch of money
off of Trump and that they promoted him
for their own pocketbook which I think
it's certainly true Jeff Zucker has
essentially said as much les Moonves at
CBS said as much it's not a great shot
okay so after all of this happened
people started to go nuts oh the White
House got very upset and Michelle wolf
they said how can Michelle wolf say all
of these things so let it be known
number one michelle wolf is a comedian
she can say any of these things should
the White House Correspondents Dinner
have had her no it obviously did not fit
with the tenor of the actual dinner it
did not do what they wanted it to do it
did not forward their agenda in any real
way in fact it's pretty
counterproductive to their agenda so the
real blame here I don't think even lies
with Michelle wolf who is I will admit I
think a really galling piece of work but
if the White House Correspondents Dinner
that decided to have her so it's on the
journalists who organized this thing not
on Michelle wolf Michelle wolf was just
being Michelle wolf
the White House Correspondents Dinner
they're the people who invited her well
White House officials were slamming
Michelle wolf they said that she was
incredibly disrespectful again I think
she was gross I think she was
disrespectful I think that there is
something weird about the White House
complaining about people being gross in
disrespectful and President Trump spent
the entire 2016 campaign ripping into
every one of his opponents as ugly and
stupid but in any case here is that
Henry talking about it what happened to
Sarah Sanders last night was disgusting
and I say that as a former president of
the White House Correspondents
Association buy the briefing tomorrow I
hope that the White House Correspondents
Association which I am a card-carrying
paid member of still you guys should put
out at least a statement an apology to
sarah sanders who you work with
professionally to go after her physical
appearance to say some of the things
that it obviously is so far beyond the
line that i hope and pray the
association apologizes to sarah Sanders
so I mean again I'm gonna try and be
fair-minded about this I don't think
that Sarah Huckabee Sanders his physical
appearance was clearly attacked I think
that everyone took all of the lines as
an attack on her physical appearance but
I'm not sure that that's actually what
happened I think there a lot of awful
things Michele will said that are just
as bad and worse about other people but
we're gonna talk about the media's
response to all of this in just a second
because as I say the White House
responding by claiming offense I think
is a little bit snow flaky but I think
that the media's response by the same
token is just as snow flaky in a
different way so here's here's what I
mean so the way that the Left responded
to the White House criticizing Michelle
wolf was by saying Michelle wolf was
some sort of great hero there's a whole
article over at vulture calm talking
about how Michelle wolf spoke truth to
power Michelle wolf did not speak truth
to power Michelle wolf just made herself
a quick buck Michelle wolf knows Stephen
Colbert made his name at the White House
Correspondents Dinner in 2005 when he
went out of his way to bash President
Bush and now the dude has David
Letterman's show and so she knows the
ten years from now she's gonna be
sitting pretty on some late night show
because she had this speak truth to
power moment so the person who took the
least risk in the room actually
was Michelle wolf because we're all
talking about Michelle wolf on Monday so
she did just fine but speaking of
hypocrites again I think it's hypocrisy
for the White House to complain about
people being mean to Trump and his
associates you know Trump himself has
been quite mean about an enormous number
of people he called Ted Cruz's wife ugly
in the middle of the campaign he said
that megyn kelly was bleeding from her
whatever like we don't have to go
through the entire campaign again but
the thing about President Trump that I
think is interesting is that the guy can
give it but he can also take it right
when Trump gets hit with a lot of these
insults he sort of smiles and he takes
it well I think the White House should
probably do the same here but here's
what the media can't see the media
demonstrates hypocrisy of its own when
they don't condemn Michelle wolf because
they say it's terrible what Trump says
okay well it's terrible what Trump says
you don't get to do it back to him do
you right there's no what about ISM here
you don't get to say Trump is awful for
saying all of these things but Michelle
wolf is so brave for saying all of these
same sorts of things about members of
the Trump administration well Donna
Brazile the former head of the DNC
that's exactly what she does she defends
Michelle wolf and she says well listen
it's okay for Michelle wolf to do it cuz
obviously Trump says gross things to
remember
we have no norms now this is a president
who has criticized women who have called
reporters some disgusting things I don't
know if there are any more lines anymore
that's that beer
that being said look come on this
president has said some we're talking
about okay Frank the person at times
says things and then he says well I'm
just joking look I'm not defending her I
would use fresh material okay
okay but here's the problem is that you
are defending her because you're saying
Trump is so awful for doing X why don't
we do X also I hate this kind of logic
when it comes from the right I hate this
kind of logic when it comes from the
left right now it's coming from the web
Kathy Griffin of course who traffics and
exactly the sort of nonsense she said
the same thing she tweeted out quote I
have some thoughts on Michelle Wolf's
act in the reaction to it from members
of the press and other DC insiders for
the record I was in the room last night
Michelle wolf set was great she was
hilarious and confidence
I like how confidence is now like a
descriptor for a comedian they like why
is it why is it a I don't understand why
that's some sort of laudatory thing that
you're confident a lot of people are
confident the question is where they're
good at their job anyway Kathy Griffin
continues you know a woman famous for
holding up a severed head model of
President Trump the calls for the White
House Correspondents Association
Michelle wolf to apologize are absurd
they're coming from reporters and many
Trump errs Trump himself has famously
never apologized because he thinks it
makes him look weak and then she
concludes by saying so journalists are
willing to demand that a comic hired to
roast people apologize but they aren't
willing to demand that Trump or his
staff apologize to people is that where
we're at now can someone explain the
difference to me
well I mean I can explain the
journalists actually did call for Trump
to apologize over and over and over he
didn't do it
so your excuse is that now the left gets
to do it as well this is why I don't
like what about it as an attack on this
sort of thing he's eventually just ends
up in the pit eventually everybody's
just slapping each other in the mud and
then if you say well that's gross they
say well yeah but you do it too well the
media what's funny about this is the
media has finally picked up on the fact
that they actually have to be above the
fray here and so five years ago they'd
probably have been okay with this sort
of thing but because Trump has been so
harsh on the media because he's gone
after them for all of their fake news
nonsense
even the media was forced to
disassociate from show Wolf's routine
even the ones who are laughing at it in
the room so NBC's Andrew Mitchell she
said listen Sarah Huckabee Sanders was
grossly insulted and deserves an apology
she says apology is owed to press
secretary and others grossly insulted
New York Michelle wolf at White House
Correspondents Association dinner which
started with uplifting heartfelt speech
by Margaret Talib comedian was worth
since Imus insulted Clinton and then
Mika Brzezinski did the same thing she
also defended Sarah Huckabee Sanders she
says watching my wife and mother be
humiliated on national television for
her looks is deplorable I've experienced
insults about my appearance from the
president all women have a do to you
tonight when these attacks happen and
the White House Correspondents
Association or Sarah an apology so folks
folks on the left are obviously aware of
the double standard that they have set
up for themselves if they were to
green-light what Michelle wolf is doing
same thing with president rub so here's
my bottom line here Michelle what's a
gross person the White House should
probably not complain too much about
this sort of stuff because President
Trump doesn't on a regular basis and the
media should not complain about Trump if
they're not gonna complain about
Michelle wolf okay end of story but the
idea that some sort of big national
story the only person who makes off like
a bandit in this whole situation is the
grossest person in the room Michelle
wolf and again the grossest thing she
said was not about a politician it was
about human babies in the womb whom she
said ought to be killed anytime you feel
like it because some men's mistresses
have paid for abortions just yuck okay
so in a second I'm gonna show you some
incredible proof of media bias but first
I want to say thanks to our sponsor is
over at zip recruiter so right now you
are hiring or you're looking to upgrade
your business if you are you need to use
zip recruiter comm because they know
there's a smarter way to get great
employees they built a platform that
finds the right job
candidates for you zipper cleaner learns
what you're looking for identifies
people with the right experience and
then invites them to apply to your job
these invitations have revolutionized
how you find your next hire in fact 80%
of employers who post a job on zip
recruiter got a quality candidate
through the site in just one day there's
a reason that we use zip recruiter out
here at daily wire zip recruiter doesn't
stop there they even spot like the
strongest applications you receive so
you never miss a great match businesses
of all sizes trust zip recruiting for
their hiring needs and right now you can
try zip recruiter for free so go to zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire that zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire again
zipper career.com slash daily wire and
you can try zip recruiter for free it
helped select the applicants make sure
that they all hit your inbox make sure
that your inbox is not clogged with
resumes it's just fantastic there's a
reason that we use it here at the daily
wear go to zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire it is indeed the smartest way
to hire again zip recruiter comm slash
daily wire use the daily wire so that we
know that it's that they know that we
sent you okay so speaking of media bias
as if the media didn't Henry acted badly
enough the White House Correspondents
Association dinner then there are some
pretty great examples of media bias over
the weekend that are just astonishing
and once again I repeat we hated the
media before Trump let's not pretend
this is about Trump it is not about
Trump Trump rightly sums up the state of
the media according to many in the
conservative movement their garbage
there's home their dumpster fire okay
one of the reasons we think their
dumpster fire is stuff like there's a
joy read over at MSNBC she's a
commentator over there enjoy read it
came out in the last couple of weeks had
a bunch of old post on her blog that
were quote-unquote homophobic or
Islamophobic you know the ones that I
saw maybe there's some other ones I
haven't seen seemed relatively mild
in any case she'd apologize for them in
the past but because joy read is kind of
a crazy person joy Reid came out and
instead of saying oopsies
sorry I did that I've changed my views
since then she suggested that instead
someone had hacked her web site retro
actively to put incriminating posts up
about her and then she came out on MSNBC
and she finally apologized and here is
what her apology sounded like but here's
what I know I genuinely do not believe I
wrote those hateful things because they
are completely alien to me but I can
definitely understand based on things I
have tweeted and have written in the
past why some people don't believe me
I've not been exempt from being dumb or
or hurtful to the very people I want to
advocate for I own that I get it and for
that I am truly truly sorry okay I'm so
confused by this what is she sorry for
exactly so she says that she doesn't
believe that she genuinely does not
believe that she said those hateful
things it is like when Ted Kennedy after
he dumped a woman in a river said that
he doesn't understand his actions were a
mystery even to himself well what no no
no no no no no no no okay so that's not
a real apology right when you apologize
for something you say what I did was
wrong it never should have happened
end of story right it never should have
happened I made the wrong decision
somebody worked for me made the wrong
decision I should have done something
about it at the time right all of that
is acceptable I've had to issue
apologies just like that in the past
because I've done things that are wrong
and I've apologized for them which is
what good people do what I didn't say
was I genuinely never below him ajik
Ferry they came down from the sky like
in Pinocchio and wrote that stuff on my
blog about how I don't like washing two
dudes kiss and Brokeback Mountain which
is what she had on her blog okay the
entire left said that this is a great
apology the entire left said okay done
here nothing more to see here we're done
we're done
now do you recall like a month ago one
month ago when Laura Ingraham apologized
publicly for making fun of David hog
saying that he was whiny about his
college admissions do you remember that
when the entire left said that's
insincere it's an insincere apology
Laura Ingraham doesn't mean that she's
only saying that because people are
coming after her advertisers hey the
only reason joy reed said this is
because people were coming after her
advertisers and because she was going to
lose her job hey the reason that she
said this is because she got in hot
water and even in her apology she
doesn't do what Laura did which is I
shouldn't have said that instead she
says I don't even believe I did it it
was just in my crazy mind I don't know
how that happened and everybody goes oh
well I guess I guess we're done here I
mean look at Jerry what a sincere him
being there's no media bias though none
none at all no media bias speaking of no
media bias Oh Tom Brokaw has now been
accused of sexual harassment okay so
according to the UK Guardian
Brokaw was accused by a former colleague
of unwanted sexual advances so what
happened what happened 60 women in the
industry signed a letter trying to
defend Tom Brokaw hey Rachel
Oh Andrea Mitchell maria shriver their
mongol group of 65 women in the US
television industry who circulated a
letter in support of Tom Brokaw Kelly
O'Donnell and Thompson Kristen Welker
also put their names to the group letter
in which the women say Brokaw 78 has
treated all of them with fairness and
respect giving them opportunities for
advancement and championing successes in
their careers broke off the letter says
is a man of tremendous decency and
integrity the letter was first reported
in The Hollywood Reporter and confirmed
by the AP hey Brokaw said that wind
investor failed in her pursuit of
stardom and was given media space to
venture grievances Wester said that
Brokaw groped her and tried to forcibly
kiss her in the 1990s Brokaw wrote that
he was angry hurt unmoored from what I
thought I would be the final passage of
my life and career so here's my question
I thought that we were supposed to be
leave all women I thought me too I
thought female solidarity and yet here
are all these female icons Rachel Maddow
Andrea Mitchell Maria Shriver signing a
letter saying Tom Brokaw is a good guy
and we don't believe Linda Wester so um
unless you have some evidence to
disbelieve Linda Wester why does this
help however you mind senior Hall
actually try to do this in the early
days with a Harvey Weinstein scandal he
got a bunch of women who were friendly
with Harvey Weinstein to come forward
and say well Harvey is actually a good
guy right I mean he's actually given me
a lot of opportunities you saw the same
thing with that there been a bunch of
media figures who have done the same
thing let's just point out that if Tom
Brokaw were a right-wing media figure
and that right-wing media figure had a
bunch of people signed a letter saying
no no this is all nonsense everyone
would say wait a second how does maria
shriver know what happened to linda
Wester how does Andrew Mitchell know
what happened to Linda Wester but again
Tom Brokaw is gonna get off because a
bunch of people on the Left say that
it's okay for him to get off speaking of
media bias I mean NBC News this is an
amazing NBC News hit job so my friend
Jordan Peterson who has become something
of a phenomenon obviously over the past
several months and who's now a
best-selling author has been for weeks
and weeks and weeks now NBC News on 60
minutes did an absolute hit job on
Jordan Peterson the apparent in a 90
minute an interview with Jordan Jordan
is not only not all right Jordan has
forcibly condemned the all right in no
uncertain terms over and over and over
so what happened NBC News labeled him
and all right intellectual and here's
what it looked like it's just an insane
thing he takes direct aim at the far
left and its effects on young men
whom he says have been hurt by a society
that over values political correctness
and pushes them away from traditional
male roles his new self-help book twelve
rules for life is already a best-seller
hundreds of thousands subscribed to his
online lectures his speeches regularly
attract protests and his new speaking
tour is selling out
feels like a movement and I'm excited to
be a partner I think he's dangerous
because of the sorts of people that he
enables journalist John sembly has
criticized Peterson is there an
ideological similarity between Jordan
Peterson and Donald Trump and his
followers I would say fundamentally yes
they both believe in this basic split of
winners and losers of hierarchies of
hierarchies being natural Peterson
doesn't apologize for his mostly male
audience and tells them not to apologize
for their privilege describing himself
as a kind of father figure get your
bloody act together but I'm on your side
using psychology religion and biology to
justify the same inequality the left
opposes what you're saying it just
sounds a bit grim doesn't it sure no no
no it sounds a lot grim okay that's just
that what in the world so I mean we have
a full hour interview coming out with
Jordan in the very near future okay I
speak with Jordan on a regular basis
this is the most ridiculous take on
Jordan Peterson I've ever seen he's
using religion to justify inequality in
what world are what are you even talking
about
what are you even talking about have you
read like anything by Jordan Peterson
here listen to anything by Jordan
Peterson okay what Jordan says is that
before you declare that inequality is
therefore inequitable you have to
determine whether there are natural
hierarchies in achievement okay what he
says is there are certain people who
achieve more in certain people who
achieve less the question is whether
they violated someone else's rights in
achieving more or less and if not then
inequality exists but that doesn't mean
it's some inequity has happened right
which is obviously true but Jordan is
apparently an all right intellectual
even though he again opposes the
outright and then they wonder and then
they wonder why we don't trust them and
then they wonder why it is that we think
that they are completely full of crap in
the media because they do ninety minute
interviews with Jordan Peterson and then
they release 30 seconds of Jordan
Peterson talking and 90 seconds of one
of his critics talking about how
terrible he is and how he's just like
Donald Trump
Jordan Peterson is just like Donald
Trump the dude was an
professor of psychology at Harvard
University you're right he's just like
Donald Trump here in a 500 page book on
the deep maps of meaning under girding
philosophy and myth not only in Western
civilization but in comparative religion
across across the world yeah that sounds
just like Trump that's just like Trump
he's an intellectual just like what in
the world and then again it's about the
only reason that we hate the media
though is apparently because we're all
rubes and Donald Trump suckered us into
it what utter absolute horse crap well
in just a second I'm gonna show you the
reaction to all of this because the
reaction to this is coming out in a very
weird way it's coming out via yeay via
Kanye I'll explain in just a second but
first I want to say thanks to our
sponsors over at Policy genius so 80% of
people think life insurance actually
cost double what it costs life insurance
is not all that expensive a healthy 35
year old can get half a million bucks in
coverage for less than 30 bucks a month
and getting life insurance doesn't have
to be complicated because there's policy
genius a policy genius is the easy way
to actually compare life insurance
online in five minutes you can compare
quotes from the top insurers to find the
best policy for you policy genius has
helped over 4 million people shop for
insurance placed over 20 billion dollars
in coverage and they don't just make
life insurance easy they also do it for
disability insurance renter's insurance
health insurance if you care about it
they have coverage for you if you've
been thinking about getting life
insurance go to policy genius.com again
the easy way to compare those top
insurers if you die without life
insurance that is your fault ok the
definitely might not be your fault but
they're not having life insurance thing
that one is your fault so go cure that
right now go over to policy genius.com
that's policy genius calm because
comparing life insurance doesn't need to
be a giant pain in the neck policy
genius.com
and of course they will get you a bunch
of various policies you can compare in
just 5 minutes try them get the get the
life insurance and ever think about it
again because after you die you won't
have to think about it and your family
will actually be taking care of policy
genius.com go check it out ok so I have
a lot to say about yeah I was informed
last week that I had said that it was
Yee which mistakenly thought that when
it was like Yee that it was like Jesus
but apparently it's yay so I've been
I've been
disabused of my mispronunciation of one
of the most important nicknames in the
history of mankind but for all of my
discussions of yay yay my discussions of
yay you'll yay to come
my discussions of yay yay you have to go
over to daily wire calm
check it out for $9.99 a month you get
the rest of this show live to get the
rest of Andrew Klavan show live there
are some Michael Noel's show live and if
you get the annual subscription you get
this the very greatest in all beverage
vessels in leftist Cheers
hot or cold tumbler still available
right now when you get that annual
subscription so check that out plus by
the way daily wire is now available at
Apple news so check that out as well
a great way to consume your news if you
just want to listen later go over to
iTunes or YouTube please subscribe
please leave this review we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
yay time for yay okay so Kanye is now
meeting with Candace Owens and Charley
Kirk which is hilarious
I know both Candice and Charley and its
really really really funny so everything
is hilarious and funny and a quick
clarification if I did not make clear
last week I think all of this is
ridiculous and stupid I think that what
Kanye is doing insofar as he is speaking
up on behalf of individualism is a good
thing but I think that the worship of
celebrity in general is hilarious and
stupid I think the worship of Kanye and
in specific is really stupid but Kanye
is is doing something that I think is
deeply necessary because the closed
mindedness of the left is so crazy
they're calling Jordan Peterson an alt
right Nick and they are suggesting that
joy Reid gave a good apology the other
day they are so closed off they have
closed the window of acceptable
discourse so tightly that anyone who is
even slightly outside that window of
acceptable discourse now must be banned
so Kanye West came out last week of
course in the greatest story in human
history and suggested that not all black
folks have to vote Democrat chance the
rapper by the way tweeted the same thing
and then backed off of it then chance
the rapper said I understand it's true
that not all black people have to vote
Democrat but I shouldn't be saying that
at this important time when Trump is
president which is like what the hell
and well what is it I mean real real
pansy move dude
I mean real pansy move if you're gonna
say the black people don't have to vote
Democrat that is true no matter who is
the president you can say I don't like
Trump but black people don't have to
vote Democrat this is true yeah but in
any case Kanye made a big splash when he
said that he's thinking for himself now
and then obviously meeting with Candace
Owens and Charlie Kirk is just more
evidence that he is thinking for himself
it's pretty fascinating in hilarious
well the now president Trump is touting
Kanye suited a speech on Saturday night
combating the White House Correspondents
Association dinner and and here is
president Trump allowing Kanye West and
by the way so good it's so good
and he saw that when he sees that
african-american unemployment is the
lowest in history you know people are
watching that's a very important thing
he's done for his legacy it's a very
important thing but Hispanic
unemployment lowest level in history
it's just incredible ok so Kanye comes
out and Trump of course is willing to go
out there and talk about and then Kanye
did something else and this actually
think it's kind of cool a cowl hood I
will acknowledge when when Kanye does
something that's cool right I think that
it's cool that he's speaking about
individualism then he did something else
you released a track called yay versus
the people I got it right this time it's
not Yi it's yay versus the people even
though it's spelled ye alright and his
his rap song is with a rapper named ti
which is of course his given name he
came out of his mother's womb and they
called him ti and and Kanye and Kanye is
rapping with ti and the point of this
rap song is that they are discussing
exactly what Kanye has been doing and he
lets Ti go at him he let's see I say
dude you're selling out black folks and
it's really terrible what you're doing
and good for Kanye right I mean this is
something that we've tried to do with
the daily wire like we used to have John
Nolte right over here John Nolte is a
very very Pro Trump guy and I disagree
with him about a lot of things but what
I said is listen it's a point of view I
think is worth clarifying and in our
conflict you can see the clarification
so Kanye is actually hosting a debate
here hey Kanye is saying come on into my
house and we're going to have a rap
battle with each other about an issue
that matters which is kind of a cool
thing I'll acknowledge this is kind of
anything now I think the song sucks but
I'm know kind of sort of rap like I
think I think all rap songs suck
basically but here's Kanye and Ti
talking about
yay-yay versus the people
[Music]
this back and forth back and forth and
if you can't hear what he's actually
saying says I never ever stopped
fighting for the people this Kanye
actually we're in this handle show
people that we equal and then Ti
responds you got to see the vantage
point of the people what you met what
you what makes you feel equal makes them
feel evil and then he says that's the
problem with this damnation all blacks
got to be Democrats man we ain't made it
off the plantation and then TI responds
f who you chooses your political party
you representing dudes just seem crude
and cold-hearted with blatant disregard
for the people who put you in position
don't you feel an obligation to them and
then Kanye responds I feel an obligation
to show people new ideas and if you want
to hear them they're go to right here
make America great again had a negative
perception I took it war rocked it gave
it a new direction at an empathy carrot
and love and affection and y'all simply
questioning my methods and can quibble
with the with the rhyme scheme there but
what he's attempting to do here is
actually something kind of neat but he's
attempting to do here is actually host
again a debate about an issue inside the
black community which is something more
than Tappin in popular culture any time
in the recent past and then at the very
end at the very end Kanye says all right
tip we could be rapping about this all
day man why don't we just cut the beat
off and let the people talk so there's
actually really cool what he did there
like I can't believe this what kanye
west did is a cool thing well Kanye West
stood is something that I've been
Shapiro approve okay I approve it it's a
good thing like this is an actual good
use of rap for opening up minds and
opening up debate and again it's not
just about him saying that he likes
Trump it's about actually opening up
debate which is really a kind of any
thing so in just a second I want to talk
a little bit about a more serious topic
but you know first I need to finish up
this kind of stuff so Kanye for people I
think let's put this way you can
appreciate what Kanye did in that song
and what he's been doing by saying to
black folks think for yourself have
individual ideas stop thinking about
identity stop thing about group identity
I don't think of yourself as black guy
and therefore you have to have this
opinion think of yourself as your name
here and now you have to have any
opinion that you want to have and that's
a really good thing that Kanye has just
done
is also incumbent on people on the right
to recognize that justice Kanye's doing
a good thing doesn't mean he's right way
Kanye is not a conservative and as pure
demonstration of this Kanye tweeted out
this the other day he tweeted out that
his hero's Emma Gonzales and Emma
Gonzales is of course the Parkland
survivor who has made a big issue of
saying that everyone who disagrees with
her is bad person just like a lot of the
other parkland survivors he says my hero
Emma Gonzales
so don't worship celebrity acknowledge
when Konya does something right and then
recognize that this dude is not reading
Edmund Burke okay he's not a guy who is
versed in the Federalist Papers now
maybe he will be maybe he'll learn that
would be great and again I'm glad that
he's opening his mind up and I'm glad
he's encouraging other people to do this
this is a direct result by the way of
the left incapacity to let people think
for themselves what's happening right
now is that the left is so intolerant
that even people who were purportedly on
the left before are saying you know I
can't deal with these people you people
are just awful proof of that comes
courtesy of a guy named Jeremy Lamb so
Jeremy Lamb is a is some dude who I've
never heard of before but he had a
hundred and sixty-nine thousand likes on
this suite there's a girl named Dom
Kezia cos he yeah she's a high school
girl very pretty white high school girl
and she is and she has pictures of
herself wearing a what looks like a
kimono basically she's wearing a she's
wearing a Chinese looking dress right to
prom and she looks very pretty in all of
this and she had some of the 57,000
likes Jeremy Lamb who's some leftist
intellectual he tweeted out my culture
is not your GG prom dress and my culture
is not your Gd prom dress now I've never
heard of this guy before he like
fourteen hundred followers on Twitter
but he now has a hundred and sixty-nine
thousand likes on that tweet so it's all
about cultural appropriation so this is
this girl in high school
wears a prom dress based on Chinese
culture and now it's all cultural
appropriation just to demonstrate how
stupid this is Jeremy lamb also tweeted
this hey Jeremy lamb also tweeted I'm
eating tamales with chopsticks this is
why America was founded what happened to
cultural appropriation Jeremy came but
the left is so but the left is so insane
that they're deeply worried about a
white girl wearing a Chinese dress
because it's beautiful not meant in any
way to disparage Chinese people there's
a difference between
somebody walking around in black face
which is disparaging right inherently
disparaging and somebody who is you know
and mocking black people and somebody
who is spending their day walking around
singing rap lyrics or my rap lyrics in
rap is a is a form of art that sprang
from Black Moon just like jazz is a form
of arts that sprang from the black
community I like jazz that cultural
appropriation know what makes America
wonderful is cultural appropriation it's
taking awesome things from other
cultures and then integrating them into
your regular life but again the left is
so intolerant that everybody must be
called out how intolerant to the left
this is an insane story there's also a
story today about I'm not kidding you a
vegan who's ripping on another vegan
because this vegan had given non vegan
ice cream to a child not joking okay
this is now intolerant crazy the left is
hey there's a woman that named avocado
hoe okay
pulled up to my driveway to find a
little girl crying she didn't have money
for the ice cream van like her friends
did so I gave her enough money to get
herself a nice big ice cream with sauce
sprinkles and a flake she was so happy
and soon had ice cream around her mouth
and her militant vegan Anthony dagger
dagger read the tweet above and then
decided to private message his fellow
vegan to chastise her and when somebody
said lighten the eff up he posted the
private messages to Twitter to call her
out so Anthony dagger wrote I usually do
not do this but I feel like this is
appropriate to post since this person is
claiming to be a vegan even though she
admitted to buying non vegan ice cream
for someone else defended what she did
when I spoke with her privately hoping
that would make her less likely to be
defensive though I should have not had
to worry about that even though I was
respectful and blocked me rather than
admitting I was right and that you
should not have bought the non vegan ice
cream for that child okay so I guess
that it's cultural appropriation some
sort of evil for a vegan to buy a non
vegan child ice cream by the way I keep
kosher if I saw a poor kid on the street
I would give that kid money to buy food
regardless of where that kid bought
kosher food because I'm not an idiot
okay but the left is so intolerant that
even if you buy food for children you
buy food for a child it has to be vegan
it has to be sjw approved food for the
child or even somehow violated the
compact of Nations and then they wonder
why people like Kanye are looking at
scans and saying guys I can't hang out
with you anymore sorry you guys are the
worst
okay so meanwhile in major world news
North Korea continues to
to be in the news there's this peace
summit that's been going on with kim
jeong-hoon arriving in south korea and
they've been having peace talks and the
South Korean Prime Minister or president
he's come out and he's said that they
are in the midst of peace talks that are
going to unify the Korean Peninsula now
there is a piece of information I'd like
to add to this talk and that is that
while Kim jong-un says that he's going
to dismantle his nuclear sites the
reality is that North Korea's nuclear
test site collapsed and may be out of
action that was reported four days
before the actual summit began so now
they're saying right now that they gave
up the North Koreans have site but in
reality and the North Koreans has I
collapsed on its own which is a pretty
good reason to say that you're gonna
give it up so according to the Guardian
North Korea's main nuclear test site has
partially collapsed under the stress of
multiple explosions possibly rendering
it unsafe er for their testing and
leaving it vulnerable to radiation leaks
a study by Chinese geologist has shown
the findings could cast doubt on North
Korea's sincerity in announcing last
weekend it would stop nuclear weapons at
the site ahead of Friday summit between
the country's leaders Kim Jong hoon and
the South Korean president moon jae-in
now I think that it is important to note
this because everybody is so all-fired
excited about everything having to do
with the North Korean situation that
suddenly Kim seems to be making all
sorts of concessions if the concessions
are not concessions your excitement is
unwarranted okay he actually has to
concede something otherwise he's just
faking you out we know this because
we're now learning that tonight Benjamin
Netanyahu is going to give a major
address from Israel in which he lists
off from a bunch of declassified
documents a bunch of information showing
that Iran has been cheating on its
nuclear deal so while the Obama bros
continue to go around talking about the
Iran nuclear deal was a great savior of
Western civilization it turns out the
Iranians have been cheating and pursuing
nuclear weapons there's great excitement
in the press about the historic nature
of the Obama Iran deal it turns out that
that was a complete disaster the same
thing could easily happen with regard to
North Korea okay time for some things I
like some things I hate and then we'll
do a quick Federalist paper so things I
like I'm gonna have to do Avengers
tomorrow because I have a few words on
Avengers and I want to get people that
next ready to see it before I spoil it
but the thing I like today is a book
called skin in the game by Nassim
Nicholas Taleb taalib the book is a
sequel to the Black Swan which was all
about sort of weird events that happen
that you can't expect skin in the game
is about the idea that if they're if
you're in the business of making
predictions
the people who actually are betting
something of themselves on that
prediction right if you are if you're
trying to follow somebody's market
advice and then you can actually have a
clearer view into their portfolio it is
better to look at their portfolio didn't
follow their market advice because
they're gonna put skin in the game
they're gonna put their money where
their mouth is anybody who's willing to
put their money where their mouth is is
obviously more trustworthy in their
predictions because they obviously
believe their own predictions one of the
big problems in the prediction business
is that there are very few effects to
making a wrong prediction right like I
actually put my money where my mouth was
in 2016 to my everlasting regret
considering I lost a bunch of money on
the 2016 election but you know at least
it was genuine or I wasn't be asking you
about the data and I nobody's put my
money where my mouth was and the same
thing is true in your life the people
who you should trust are the people who
are willing to sacrifice for their
position not the people who are not
willing to sacrifice for their position
okay time for a couple of things that I
hate okay so the thing that I hate
number one Pope Francis came out and
tweeted something really really dumb
somebody asked me in the mailbag a
couple of weeks ago ago about Pope
Francis and what I thought of him and I
said I thought that he was more of a
Liberation Theology than anything else I
think that he's a far left think her
here's what he tweeted quote do we
really want peace then let's ban all
weapons so we don't have to live in fear
of war oh I'm glad you thought of this
if only someone had thought in history
about banning all weapons also as Jonah
Goldberg asks how would you enforce this
ban
how would you make sure that no one can
have weapons make that require a weapon
to ensure that no one has a weapon also
before there were complex weapons the
death rate in society was actually
significantly higher than it is now so
all of this is deeply stupid but
pie-in-the-sky solutions seem to be
something that Pope Francis is very fond
of I am NOT a big fan of this particular
Pope I think that his predecessors were
much better than he at his job so there
is that okay
other things that I hate gyms commis
still hanging around and my favorite
thing about James Comey is that he's
trying to pretend he's not cashing in
when he is clearly cashing in so here's
James Comey on Meet the Press trying to
explain that he's not actually cashing
in he is I cannot imagine why an FBI
director would seek to essentially cash
in on a book when the investigation it's
very much alive
should have waited to do his memoir
should you wait it I hope she'll read it
and and see that it's not about the
investigation it's about not even about
Donald Trump it's about something much
broader that I thought it was important
to talk about now okay no that's no no
no no no you're here for the gash okay
we all understand your hurtful Akash
just say you're here for the cache say
listen I was gonna tell the story one
way or another I may as well am I gonna
pretend that I'm not making some money
off this book of course I'm not gonna
pretend that but I think it's important
to get it out there but the whole I am
just so far above the fray routine not
not effective okay
time for a quick Federalist Papers so as
I say every week we do a Federalist
paper we are all the way up to
Federalist 26 and making steady progress
through the Federalist Papers been doing
it now for six months obviously so
Alexander Hamilton wrote Federalist 26
and in this Federalist paper he talks
about the the possibility that's being
posed by a lot of the states that maybe
the National Legislature should not be
able to exercise more making Authority
which raises the question okay who
should be able to exercise war-making
Authority should be the executive
probably not because then that would
make them the king should it be the
legislature well it's not the
legislature who else would it be so
Alexander Alexander Hamilton says the
legislature is the proper place for
funding and maintaining a standing army
and that's been true in Britain since
the Glorious Revolution and then he as
the legislature of the United States
will be obliged by this provision once
at least in every two years to
deliberate upon the propriety of keeping
a military force on foot to come to a
new resolution on the point and to
declare their sense of the matter by a
formal vote in the face of their
constituents they're not at liberty to
vest in the executive department
permanent funds for the support of an
army if they were in even and cautious
enough to be willing to propose it in it
so improper a confidence he's saying
that the legislature has to remain in
control so we can argue about whether to
grow or shrink the military obviously in
reality the military has continuously
grown since so at least Bill Clinton's
days Barack Obama tried to cut it back
somewhat Bill Clinton tried to cut it
back somewhat but for different reasons
simply because they believe the United
States should not be as muscular on the
world stage the legislature has not in
fact been a good check on the executives
war-making Authority the founders
believe that the legislature should be a
check on that because they believed that
the executive branch was always going to
have an impetus toward growth of the
military and growth of intervention ISM
it's time for the legislature to take a
lot of that authority back which they
have not done and I hope that at some
point they will already so we'll be back
in my
with much much more as I say Bendre
minutes now who from Israel's supposed
to make a big statement tonight about
the Iran deal and we will cover all of
it tomorrow
i'm ben shapiro this is the bench
shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Jesuit Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright floor publishing